from edgar wright until he refused to
get in line comes a movie based on a
superhero so ridiculous you'll swear
marvel's choosing the projects on a dare
ant-man you've seen Marvel movies based
on green giants Norse gods and these
weirdos now get ready for a hero so
silly no one can even keep a straight
face when they say his dumb name ant-man
ant-man it's a to change the name in
this super powered heist film that
against all odds actually kind of works
I mean it's still more believable than
letting someone join The Avengers just
because they're good with a bow and
arrow right meet Scott leg say yes God
wait nope not that one yeah that's the
guy a master thief who gets busted every
time he tries to get away with anything
hey guy his life will change when he
meets Hank Pym the billionaire
industrialist who lost control of his
company to evolve former ally who
betrays him and plots to uses advanced
suit technology for evil and if that
sounds familiar
it's because it's the exact same premise
as the first Iron Man movie if it ain't
broke I mean seriously
it even has that friend staring at the
suit though we're in the sequel moment
next time thrill at amazing visual
effects that makes 70 year old Michael
Douglas look like 60-year old Michael
Douglas and has harmless locations pulse
with epic danger like a briefcase a toy
train set and Michael Pena's jog
in some of the most high-stakes fights
between tiny people
since Frodo versus Gollum proving
marbles still hasn't run out of ways for
guys to punch each other in the face or
in this movie's case sucker punch and
now it's gonna blow up in your face
that's how you punch
prepare for a movie that would be really
stale without Paul Rudd doing Paul Rudd
things because most of it is Hank Pym
yammering on about some boring science
crap I used to lecture magnetic waves to
stimulate their olfactory nerve center
must retrieve this prototype of a signal
decoy I created a formula that altered
atomic relative distance huh she turned
off her regulator he went set the topic
but separates itself from the other 11
MCU movies with a few unique twists like
making another schlubby comedian get abs
for a superhero role actually getting
you to care about disgusting insect
monsters no I like that one because he
had a name and saying the one thing
everyone's been yelling at the screen
since phase 2 started I think our first
move should be calling the Avengers so
strap in for the best micro movie since
Honey I Shrunk the Kids as Marvel proves
once again they can literally sell you
anything and they don't even have to try
that hard to sell it
huh story I love you Matt
Tony Stark senior wasp machine the only
Latino in the MCU Ti as himself as the
biggest Avenger they could get Thomas
and the magic railroad and disposable
Marvel villain number nine tiny Iron Man
man after this one I cannot imagine
these movies getting any strange oh yeah
I forgot about that
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers Darth Jar Jar hello from the
other side jingle balls and debt the
halls triple dent gum will make you
smile
triple dn't gum at last for awhile I
thought she was with you